burned alive or slaughtered in their
homes the parents hiding their newborn
babies before confronting the terrorists
children and elderly people ripped from
their families taken hostages even
Holocaust Survivors over 1,300 human
beings were murdered by barbaric
terrorists of Hamas against
Israel they aimed to eradicate Jewish
life from the land and they took action
this is the most heinous assault against
Jews since the
Holocaust we thought this could never
happen again yet it did in the face of
this unspeakable tragedy there's only
one possible response Europe stands with
Israel and Israel has the right to
defend itself in fact it has the duty to
defend its people and we must call by
their name the atrocities committed by
Hamas this is Terrorism this is an act
of War nothing can can justify what
Hamas did this is the time to stand in
solidarity with Israel and its people
and this is why I am here let me also be
very clear that Hamas alone is
responsible for what is happening Hamas
acts have nothing to do with the
legitimate aspiration of the Palestinian
people on the contrary the horror that
Hamas has Unleashed is only bringing
more suffering on innocent Palestinians
they are threatened too Hamas despicable
actions are the Hallmark of terrorists
and I know that how Israel responds will
show that it is a
democracy in recent days I've also been
in contact with King abdulla Jordan and
president at cisi of Egypt Europe will
keep working for peaceful and integrated
Middle East we know that Hamas actions
risk to affect the his historic Rushmore
between Israel and its Arab
neighbors and we should observe very
closely those who stand to gain from a
perpetuating conflict in the Middle East
like Iran and Russia so now is the time
to work even more closely with Israel
and with countries in the region for
stability and Against Terror finally
Jewish communities across the world are
also deeply affected including in Europe
anti-semitic incidents are gaining are
again on the rise and this is
unacceptable we are deeply concerned by
the spread of online hate and speech and
fake news which are proliferating at
worrying speed and even difficult to
keep track of we are already in contact
with social media platforms to remind
them of their
obligations there is no place and zero
tolerance for hate in Europe both online
and offline against
anyone over the past years the European
Union has put the fight against
anti-Semitism and fostering Jewish life
in Europe at the heart of our action
like never before this is the moment for
all of us to stand together thank you
very much thank you Ula U I appreciate
the expression of support that you gave
now and in the recent days and the fact
that so many European countries
countries have stood with us and uh
shoulder toh shoulder uh these are not
merely acts of War these are war crimes
what Hamas has done is to perpetrate the
worst war crime since the Holocaust the
burning of people alive putting them
cramming young people in a
room putting bringing spare tires from
Cars so there's more Flames burning them
alive this is the Holocaust method
shooting babies bound children shooting
them in the face killing uh children
before in front of their parents killing
parents in front of their children the
rape and murder of women the kidnapping
of uh old people young people families
tearing them
away you saw the picture of that little
boy
pushed
beaten uh it reminds us of the pictures
from the worst periods of the Holocaust
so if Hamas could have its way it would
do to us exactly what the Nazis did to
the Jews they would kill every last one
of us they would mutilate our bodies
they would behead us and that's what
they did and therefore it is important
to understand Hamas perpetrated the
worst war crimes since World War II and
Hamas is Isis in some respects uh as
President Biden has said they're worse
than Isis and so they have to be treated
the way Isis was treated the
International Community banded together
to eradicate
this this uh horrible Scourge uh and I
appreciate the fact that the
International Community and Europe is
standing behind Israel so that we can
eradicate this Scourge we are doing so
uh I think in the front line of
civilization this is the front line of
civilization between and barbarism and
we have to assure that nobody meets with
a barbar
it doesn't have there are not diplomatic
relations with Isis there are not
diplomatic relations with Al-Qaeda after
911 uh and there's no harboring states
that Harbor Hamas representation are
harboring Isis or Al-Qaeda that's
Unthinkable there should be a a concrete
position of the International Community
to apply sanctions on countries that do
so if we stand United then civilization
will win and Israel appreciat
appreciates the support that you are
giving us in this these trying times and
I'm sure we'll have other ideas that
we'll talk about in our meeting thank
you or thank you thank
you thank you thank
[Music]
you I think there's a tremendous
rul right now we need
[Music]
to